[Music]
in southern texas just a few miles from
the mexico border and almost three hours
from san antonio sits the quiet town of
del rio
texas is a place where local politics
are often steeped in anti-lgbt rhetoric
but in a wave of change del rio elected
its first openly gay mayor in 2018.
i'm zoe saldana from bc and i'm teaming
up a great big story to shine a light on
american latinx excellence around the
country
i'm bruno lozano and i'm the mayor of
del rio texas
i was born and raised here in dario
texas
i joined the military when i was 21
i served in the air force under don't
ask hotel
i laughed and lived in big cities
and i came back to del rio texas in
2016.
[Music]
i was not openly gay until maybe i was
15 years old
growing up i was bullied because i was
flamboyant i was feminine i was more
feminine and being feminine is
considered a weakness in the machismo
culture that permeates this entire area
but the same people who bullied me voted
me into office
bruno ran on a platform built on
infrastructure employment and tourism
despite running against an incumbent
bruno won his election with 62 percent
of the vote
i decided to run for office because i've
always believed in del rio and his full
potential
on my campaign trail i did not run as a
gay politician or as a gay mayor i ran
as bruno who happens to be all of these
other things miss carpenter you may now
have the floor to speak for three
minutes
you can win people's hearts over as long
as you are true to yourself and true to
your mind and goal
[Music]
since becoming mayor bruno has written
support resolutions for local
initiatives appointed members of the
parks committee and housing authority
but most importantly he has created a
space for people like him
for me the future of del rio is being a
place where people are welcome are
inviting and are different
i left looking for acceptance and
looking for people like me but i chose
to come back to del rio because my
community is here and it's important for
people who are different like myself to
be visible
you can be gay you can be different and
you can still run for office here in del
rio texas and win an election
[Music]
you